so I I have to ask on several aspects of
China first on the
president uh the meeting you helped set
up a first call and first meeting
between Donald Trump and uh Xin ping can
you tell the story of that because
that's also interesting again that first
phone call the reaching out the the
forming the human connection which
ultimately leas the connection between
nations and the possibility of
collaboration so during the transition
president Trump took a call from the uh
the head of Taiwan and that sent the
Chinese into a a real Tail Spin and he
didn't do it I think to be provocative
to them as much as just as a businessman
he felt you answer your call somebody
wants to speak to you you speak to them
like you you want to have conversations
hear their point of view and but it was
taken as a very big insult and it was
against tradition and Norm um and so
that was something that set us off in in
a wrong
direction my view at the time was that
you know we are kind of entering a G2
World whether people want to admit it or
not and that a lot of these countries in
what I call the Middle Market countries
were basically playing this when China
was being aggressive with their one belt
one road they were basically playing us
and China against each other and I
thought that by the two leaders coming
together there were some things they
wouldn't agree on uh but there was a lot
that they probably could agree on which
could lead
to um resolutions to a lot of issues uh
in the world that that that was like my
most optimistic view um my my most more
pragmatic view was that President Trump
had very big issues on trade that he
wanted to get to with China you know he
felt like China their Trade Practices
were unfair they weren't following all
the global rules of trade uh he was a
little bit nervous that they would be
provocative with Taiwan and I felt like
the two of them getting together would
be the best way to try and resolve that
so um the Chinese are very proud and a
lot of it is about face and so we in
order to negotiate for that first call
we we basically agreed on what would
happen in the call so not let's just
have a call say hi nice to meet you was
a question of President Trump basically
agreed that he would acknowledge the one
China policy which he didn't see as a
big concession because you could always
un acknowledge it the next day so yeah
I'll acknowledge it and then we'll go
and exchange uh president Chi was going
to come over to the US for a visit so
they could sit together and they want to
do it outside the White House and so we
agreed on MAR logo which I also thought
was good because president Trump always
felt much more comfortable when he was
hosting at his properties and he just
felt at home and so he liked having
people as his guests and he loved he
loved it he always felt really relaxed
and and it was great so that was really
what we did then the Chinese come over
very much anticipated visit and it was
incredible so they were supposed to sit
together for 15 minutes uh and um they
sent about an hour and a half together
and during that meeting President Trump
they said look let's just set some
ground rules to this relationship like
let's just not talk about Taiwan like
you know just don't do anything I don't
want on the table if it does I'm going
to have to do harsh things
I just don't want this to be a problem
for four years we got bigger issues they
basically just again you notice four
years of trump Administration no Taiwan
talk whatsoever it was a non-issue
started talking about the trade issues
they spent a lot of time on North Korea
uh president Trump was trying to get the
perspective from uh from president XI
about North Korea because that was again
considered from Obama the biggest
national security issue that we faced at
the time and um and they just had a good
feeling for each other it also helped
that you know uh my wife and I uh we we
actually had a a Chinese uh Nanny and
teacher in our house and our our kids
learned fluent Mandarin and uh our
daughter actually opened when uh
president she and president Trump were
together with h with Melania and with uh
Madame Pang is is um uh my daughter
actually sang them a couple of Chinese
songs and uh and I thought that was a
nice way to show you know we're tough
but we respect your culture because the
Chinese have an incredible culture that
goes back thousands of years they're
very proud and in how um and how they do
it and I think that sign of respect also
set things off in a very warm way for
president Trump to say my granddaughter
speaks Chinese and and we're showing you
the respect um which I think is very
important and he did have respect for
them the next part about the visit I
mean obviously we had a lot of
discussions on trade but the part that
was probably most impactful to me was
President XI basically did an hour
monologue uh at lunch where he just went
through uh Chinese history from his
perspective and he t aled about U with
particular emphasis on on kind of the
Treaty of unequals and then the 100
Years of
humiliation and then you go through from
ma all the way to today and you had you
know China coming back and rising and
you could tell that he was learned the
lessons from the past and was very
committed to kind of seeing China go
through so that was a different time
right so China today is different than
it was in 2017 in
2017 I remember president XI was at
Davos and he was FedEd by all the top
business people in the world as the you
know Donald Trump was the threat to the
global World Order president XI was the
champion of free trade and the biggest
champion of environmentalism and and and
fighting for climate change and um and
what occurred was President Trump came
in and basically said like I think China
has not been following the rules-based
order uh took very very drastic
approaches with tariffs every time he
would do the tariffs again you know I
had manuch and our treasury sector would
come to vonka my house if does this this
is going to crash the whole economy I
mean these and by the way he believed it
I mean these were things that people
were telling him would be very tough to
do you know president Trump had a had a
gentleman named Ambassador lighthiser
Robert lighthiser he was really the the
tip of the spear on all of our our trade
negotiations he worked very well with
secretary minuchin and they ended up we
ended up increasing tariffs to numbers
that hadn't
um even been thought could happen so we
did the first round of tariffs then uh
you know the Chinese came back and
retaliated very surgically trying to hit
us in all the areas that politically
would have been difficult and what Trump
did was instead of backing down he took
some of the revenue from the tariffs
gave it to the farmers and said I know
that this going to hurt your business
but I'm going to make sure you guys are
made whole and then he doubled down and
basically went back at the Chinese with
even more tariffs so what we watched
over a year and a half was probably the
biggest hand of Poker that was ever
played and it was an amazing uh
experience to be a part of it and the
role I played was really working for sec
minuchin and Ambassador lighthiser as a
as a back Channel with the Chinese to
make sure we can just deescalate things
and get to Solutions in a uh in the best
way possible and so um so anyway it was
a fascinating time but if you think
about the global awareness of the the
bad practices that China was putting in
place today versus what they were in
2016 I think one of President Trump's
most successful policies was Shifting
the way the entire world understood the
threat of China and then putting in
place the beginning of a regime to try
and rebalance the world so that we could
have more economic parity so you
mentioned to me the book the 100-year
marathon by Michael
Pillsbury uh when we discussed
China and uh I've gotten a chance to
read parts of it and i' highly recommend
people read it because there's a few
it's a definitely an eye openening
perspective I don't know if I agree with
with all of it I don't know if you agree
with all of it but it certainly opens it
gives a very intense perspective on
China and you said it was instructive to
how you thought how Donald Trump thought
about
China uh can you describe the main
thesis of the book and maybe with the
hopeful view how it's possible to have a
trajectory of these two superpowers
working together in the 21st
century uh versus fighting against each
other perfect so um it's a very very big
book and I I I think it's a book
definitely worth reading Michael is uh
is is is tremendous he speaks fluent uh
Mandarin and so he he spent a lot of
time researching to do the book so I
highly recommend it to everyone and it
was considered more of a fringe
perspective uh in 2016 but it really I
think came to represent the underpinning
of what uh the collective thought was of
the Trump
Administration and um and maybe you
could argue that it was even more
cynical the the whole thesis of the book
was that
China from 1949 to 2049 was working to
reclaim their position as the global
leader right so you had the the Chinese
Empire um you know one of the things I
don't know if it's from this book or a
different book that I read that spoke
about how in the late 1700s basically
the Emperor of China was offered some of
the industrial capability from England
which was basically now becoming an
industrial uh the Industrial Revolution
and basically no we're fine we're the
great Chinese Empire we don't we don't
need any of these things we're were
better than that and by rejecting that
the rest of the world got stronger China
remained weaker uh then you had the the
the the Opium Wars you know the the
Chinese had big opium problems through
all the trade back and forth and then
China from about 1840 to to 1940 at a
100 years where they really after all
these uh treaties were really a second
class country and so then you have the
people's Revolution that comes in and he
talks about how China very strategically
is a very very poor country
um you know would fight their way back
and and build Brick by Brick and you
know he propers in the book that Nixon
didn't go to China and open China it was
China that actually went to Nixon and
was able to use Nixon in order to open
up then they talk about how under Carter
they were able to get the US to
contribute to a lot of their uh they
were able to kind of start borrowing the
us knowhow from our University Systems
from our medical from our science from
our research and the whole notion that
was the conventional thinking of
American leaders was that the more we
helped China advaned the more they would
become a free market economy and it was
a great Market the only difference was
was that they weren't allowing us access
they were making our companies basically
give them all of their technical
knowledge they were stealing our
intellectual property uh they were doing
Espionage to to steal a lot of the
patents they were just ignoring our
patents and they weren't following any
of the rules of international trade then
they started becoming the world's
manufacturing Hub they basically became
the world's Factory and then they
started this whole initiative called the
belt and Road initiative and in order to
start locking in their lines of trade
they were buying up all the ports
everywhere they were building Railways
thinking how do we we lock in our
distribution so that we can maintain the
dominance as the world's Global Factory
and so it was a brilliant long-term plan
that they were doing and by raising
awareness by putting the tariffs Trump
slowed them down a lot um the real
question is is if they actually did
achieve this full objective of becoming
the world uh dominant country what they
would have done with it whether they
would have been nefarious or not I think
from my perspective even with some of
the divisions and issues we have now in
America I still would rather an American
Leed World daughter than a Chinese Leed
World daughter um but the notion was is
that they were playing a very Zero Sum
game and really going to be the dominant
leader in this new world order so um so
that really framed the perspective and
it wasn't necessarily you know people
asked me was was and the Chinese were
always fearing is Trump trying to stop
our rise right and you have a great book
also by Allison that he writes about you
know are we destined for war between us
and China and he goes through different
historical times where you have a power
and a rising superpower and I think you
know more than half the time it ends up
leading to war so the question is is
what's going to happen here and I I do
think that Trump's perspective and this
is my interpretation because everything
was always tactical dayto day and you
know he was unpredictable to the Chinese
which they couldn't deal with and he was
unpredictable even to his team sometimes
because he was playing it day by by day
and issue by issue and always changing
and adjusting which is how an
entrepreneur thinks he respected the job
they did by building their country they
moved 300 million people out of poverty
into the middle class they did it at the
expense of a lot of other countries
throughout the world especially America
but Trump says look stupid politicians
made deals I respect China for doing
what they did but what I want to do is I
want to change the Paradigm so that for
the next 20 years we can maintain our
advantage over them we can maintain our
competitive Dynamic and you know his
General view was that America is the
best private sector in the world we have
a lot of the best Minds uh in the world
and if we can just have a Level Playing
Field with set rules then America should
be able to outperform and so that's
really what we were trying to do we were
trying to kind of get rid of some of
their stap subsidies get rid of make
them follow some of these International
rules of trade and um and not allowing
them to do predatory um Investments that
then undercut different industries that
we had so that they can have global
market dominance or monopolies on
different Industries and then have
pricing power but also um you know
geopolitical power so like one of the
examples that people talk about now is
China for the last 20 years was very
Advanced on seeing this electrification
trend they went they they they
subsidized solar panels a lot of the
American solar panel players were put
out of business so now I think it's like
90 plus% of solar panels in the world
are you manufactured in China than all
the rare Earths that you need in order
to make these solar panels and to make
these electric vehicles China's bought
up most of them and a lot of the
refining capacities in China so thinking
through strategically how do we create
an even playing field so that we're not
at the mercy of them and how you can
have a rules-based world order that was
really kind of the thought of what we
were trying to work
towards
that